half a dozen being burned on the streets
of Haiti's Capital victims of vigilante
justice supposed gang members and broad
daylight and then set on fire by
residents according to Witnesses those
who live in the neighborhood ready to
fight back
[__]
if they come [__] with us we got
machetes for them that's what he said no
you got to do with the energy
yeah
this energy yeah well if you understand
Corral is honestly one of the best
things just hearing them talk they [__]
let's come to invade us we will defend
ourselves we have our own weapons we
have our machetes we'll take their
weapons we will not run away mothers who
want to protect their children can send
them elsewhere
we were right there we were there we
were there we were right there we
actually filmed a little document while
we were in Haiti so you guys that look
like right there uh that's close to that
Lucy or something like that I'm not sure
it is I don't think it is the violence
had started in the early hours of the
morning when criminal gangs burst into
several homes and attacked residents
hours later Police Stopped and searched
the minibus supposedly containing
several gang members according to
officials a mob saw this as a chance for
Revenge police stabbed them and they
went yo yo call the people them the
folks showed up and the cops went
all right we left the handcuffs off
we'll be back in 10 minutes they came
back with some gasoline lit these people
on fire and now there's a lot of folks
who are up in arms about this because
they're seeing all this vigilantism the
police arrested the dudes yeah this is
actually interesting we will be back
after these messages will be right back
and left them with the people and then
it went that's the sound of the people
and then the people that whatever people
had to do listen I'm laughing because
this [__] is outrageous I'm not laughing
out I'm laughing at this [__] out it's
crazy I knew this thing was gonna happen
we'll explain why we're not bothered by
most of us in the middle during a search
of a mini bus in which there were armed
individuals the police confiscated
weapons and other equipment in addition
more than a dozen individuals traveling
in this vehicle were unfortunately
unfortunately lynched
I mean you know this said what's up you
know we confiscated their weapons we
managed to you know arrest them and
unfortunately so what happened was I was
on guard right and I was able to seize
their weapons because that's what was
supposed to do as the police and then I
had to walk out and to get a coffee
because you know it was my break and
then and then I said to someone I said
oh [__] look at the people that caught
so I went in to get a coffee and then I
came back and
um like oopsie Daisy yeah and went from
barbecue chicken to barbecue gang member
[__] hit different smell different too
the violence underlines the increasingly
Lawless situation in poho pass
criminal gangs have taken control over
an estimated 60 percent of the city
since the assassination of President
juvenile Moyes nearly two years ago
on Monday United Nations Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez called for the
deployment of an international Armed
Force to Haiti in a desperate attempt to
temper the escalating violence
it comes as a un report highlighted the
surge in murders and kidnappings in the
country with special emphasis on City
Soleil an area of the capital that has
become besieged by gangs who are
blocking access in and out okay so a
little bit of backstory he's been going
through a downturn economically speaking
uh for a variety of reasons but in large
part due to corruption okay and foreign
intervention now
knowing all this things are deteriorated
where getting gasoline getting any job
opportunities is very difficult and
it'll end up happening after the last
president got assassinated by Foreign
mercenaries
um was at the city and the country
itself was devolved into more
lawlessness and gangs who took over
engaged the kidnapping taking of
children indiscriminate murder
anything you could imagine that they did
they did to the locals and foreigners
this is very unsafe over there
so this brings us to today
where now you have gangs running around
just catching gang members and burning
them alive it's funny because the police
officers and the police force used to be
seen as Terrible by the local population
and now they're starting to work in
conjunction with the local police force
to take out the gang members that is
quite the transition ain't it it is it
is a crazy transition and it's something
I understand because you know there's
only you know
some people say it's like there's only
so much [__] some people can take you
know there's only so much fear you can
put in people's heads before they go
crazy
you could only make someone so afraid
for so long before they just retaliate
and the reality is the situation over
there so dangerous and so frightening
for most of the locals that they're just
like bro you can't scare us no more
we're just going to take it from you and
so yeah burning people in the streets
probably not something that should
happen here in Canada but over there I
don't care because they gotta offend for
themselves and nobody else is going
there to defend them and you know what I
found out there's people from Montreal
who are actually funding a lot of the
local militias some of them yeah the
problem with that is that whenever you
do The Village at empty thing there's
not a proper trial and you can catch
innocent people and that's very
unfortunate
Becky evolves to that
unfortunately that's where we at with
that situation hey man that's where we
at that's where we at
we're 80. I knew this was going to
happen I remember when we went to Haiti
in 2015 to shoot that documentary I said
that I said you know what's gonna happen
the people are gonna take over at some
point the people is going to take over
they're going to do a coupe if you don't
know
is was our revolution in 1804 and that
led to us being free right that's when
the slave rolled up and they would be
like you know what we're not taking this
thing no more okay
and yeah I said this was gonna happen
and I was not the only one saying that a
lot of the locals that I was speaking to
were saying that as well and now
here we are I'll go it's like let me
talk about digital autism and innocent
people getting hurt but honestly it's
like taking antibiotics it doesn't just
flush out the bad stuff
sometimes you got to hurt the good stuff
a little bit too to be able to get rid
of the really bad infections and that's
what this is like yeah so you know this
is not gonna be a perfect solution but
there are none it's like all the other
solutions that they tried and they try
to just do and bring to you win and
endure independent good thing and then
like and endure and bring the UN in
there and you win take over the
advantage uh people be taking people
from the the the US and then people from
the U.S take advantage people
bring people from Canada people from
Canada take advantage and bring the Red
Cross there uh raise six million dollars
build six houses you know where's the
money we don't know a bunch of stuff
like that so when you keep on keep on
pressing and keep on putting people and
cornering them that's what happens
so
I said it before only Haiti's gonna
I don't mind vigilance Justice
societies that are not you know able to
function
people got to do what they got to do
they got to do what they gotta here I
would never accept it over there I got
no problem with it and so that's a
difference and you know people will want
to say stuff you see these foreign
entities talking about oh this is
unacceptable unacceptable you [__]
didn't lift a finger to help anything
over there don't be telling them how to
solve their problems when you helped
create many of them and now you want us
[__] chastising for how they handle
it
nobody should have to endure living in
an environment where gang members write
everything take your kids take your
wives take your people till you ask for
rent some money no no nobody should have
to if that was the case here in Canada I
would have no issue with people doing
that or anywhere else in the world none
this whole talk about but you don't know
Hey listen it is what it is
it really is there's no way you can sit
there and have this much to say if you
were living there for even a day
there's not a chance
so that's what I think about this good
sometimes in some of this instant
Justice don't sound too bad to be even
here
that's a bit
about to say being honest
there's a couple times I've seen some
people on camera marking two three
people and I'm like
somebody get the gas line
it's not a good thing but it is what I
feel anything else
no oh yeah I mean you know people might
say to yourself about Haiti and all this
stuff but when we went five years ago
maybe six years ago now it was a good
time it was amazing it was amazing even
when things was like we say even when
things are crazy that sounds bad things
look like yeah we were there right in
the middle of one of some of the biggest
protests during the World Cup that [__]
was crazy
um but even knowing that my experience
over there was wonderful the people were
great my experience in the country was a
lot of fun very very beautiful so yeah
it's unfortunate to see what's happening
there
um I hope that Haiti gets to recover
from all this as have recoveries happen
a lot of African nations so I hope it
Formed
um but yeah anything else no all right
let us know what you guys think